[Musik]
bild breaking news
willkommen zurück hierbei bild live an
diesem montag mit dem spektakulären
feuer in hamburg und das mitten im
berufsverkehr mitten in hamburg
ausgerechnet nämlich unter den so
bekannten elbbrücken dort unter der
bahnstrecke hat wie sie sehen hier ein
40 tonner gebrannt der fahrer das ist
die gute nacht er konnte sich da zum
glück aus retten der rauch aber der war
über der ganzen stadt zu sehen und für
die feuerwehr als mehr als so
kompliziert unter der brücke zu löschen
riesige hitze natürlich dort ja aber mit
viel schaum man sie gerade schon gesehen
ist das dann am ende gelungen jetzt muss
erst mal gecheckt werden ob die brücke
das alles so richtig gut überstanden hat
oder ob sie vielleicht noch ein paar
risse bekommen hat möglicherweise sogar
einsturzgefährdet ist immerhin der
zugverkehr der war stundenlang
unterbrochen der rollt jetzt wieder und
auch der autoverkehr gab nämlich so
richtig verkehrschaos heute früh in der
hansestadt wegen dieses feuers
[Musik]